The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so last time we
were talking about
symmetries of SCET.
We talked in detail
about gauge symmetry,
and we started to talk about
reparameterization invariance,
and we are going to
continue with that today.
So reparameterization
invariance in SCET
is kind of rich,
because we have lots
of things that are messing
up Lorentz invariance.
But we started out talking about
three different types here.
One where we rotate the n,
the physical n vector that
was the direction
of our collinear
particles to some other vector
that's equally good, which
I call n prime in the figure.
So a type one, transformation.
Or we could change this
auxiliary vector, n bar,
by a large amount.
That was type two.
Or we could change both
at n and n bar in a way
that dot products
remain invariant.
That's type three.
So all three of these
preserved these relations,
n squared equals 0, n
bar squared equals 0.
n dot n bar equals 2.
And really, these
transformations
are just giving us a different
basis for our decomposition,
which satisfies all the things
that we wanted that basis
to satisfy.
Doesn't change any of
our power counting,
and so is an equally
good description
for the effective theory.
And therefore, we want
to have invariance
under these transformations.
So we're restoring Lorentz
symmetry in this way.
We break it by
introducing these vectors,
but we're restoring it in a
way by having transformations
on these factors.
But it's not, you're
not restoring,
if you like, it's still
different than Lorentz
symmetry, for example,
because you're not
making huge transformations
of the vector n
here for any arbitrary
transformation.
And it is a
reparameterization not
a Lorentz symmetry in general.
So we'll talk more
about how this connects
to the HQET one in a minute.
But if we have a vector, then
obviously the vector, p mu--
I don't write the
right hand side--
is invariant to what
choice of basis I use.
So that means that this
p mu should not change.
And that means if
I change n here,
let's say I do a type one,
then I'll change n here
and I'll change n here.
But I must compensate those
changes by changing what--
perp also depended
on the meaning of n,
so there will be a compensating
change for the perp
So we can figure out from
statements like this what
the transformation laws are.
So this guy is invariant
to the decomposition.
So the transformation
of p perp mu
compensates for n in type
one, or n bar in type two.
Type 3 is already
invariant because we
have an n and an n bar here,
an n and an n bar here.
So that's type three
invariant already.
So if we go through
that, we can make
a table of all the
different transformations,
and we can derive
the transformations.
We also have to do the same
thing that we did in HQET,
because we also-- the
other important fact
is that we have a projection
relation out here.
So we also have this,
and you'll remember
that when we talked about
reparameterization invariance
and HQET, the
projection relation was
part of the discussion,
and so that's true too.
But let me just quote
to you the results,
that you could kind of get
an impression for where
these various terms
are coming from.
So let's summarize,
first, type one.
So type one was n goes
to n plus delta perp.
So if you have
something like n dot D,
That goes to n dot D
plus delta perp dot D,
there's a transformation
of p perp or D perp.
Let me write it as D perp.
This is really for
any vector which
has to compensate for the
transformation of the n
in the way I described.
There's a transformation
like that.
The n bar component under
type one does not transform.
And if you go
through the spinner,
or you go through the field,
the fermion field, it does get--
because the projection
relation has a transformation,
there's a transformation
of this guy.
The Wilson line,
which we talked about,
was only a function
of M bar dot A,
and so it doesn't
get transformed.
So that's what type
one transformations
would look like.
And type two--
Summarize.
They start out looking
the same, and then there's
some differences.
So everything so far looks
exactly the same as type one,
just with a sort of
suitable replacement.
But the fermion ends up looking
a little more complicated here.
And the Wilson line
also transforms
because the Wilson
line was built out
of n bar dot D field, so.
Working the first order
in that transformation,
there's an additional term.
Epsilon perp dot D perp.
OK, so I didn't want to take you
through the derivation of all
these equations.
I have provided references.
There's a reference list at
the beginning of the notes,
and there's a reference with
a paper that talks about how
to derive these equations.
We won't be spending too
much time talking about it.
So I won't go through
the derivation,
but it's very analogous to
what you would do in HQET.
So how do we use these results?
Let's take them as given.
We can use these
results to close out
our discussion of what we
were talking about last time,
and show what the leading
order Lagrangian is,
imposing all the symmetries.
And so the first
thing that we can note
is that if we do a type one
transformation of this guy,
and you simplify
the result, then
at the end of the day that boils
down to just the following.
Well, it can be simplified
to a single term.
And if one does the
same thing on this guy,
then that gives us the same
turn, with the opposite sign.
So these two operators are
connected by reparameterization
invariance.
The sum of them is
reparameterization invariant,
and that looks good.
So the sum is 0,
connected by RPI.
And that means, for
example, that you couldn't
have any non-trivial Wilson
coefficient between them
or anything like that.
Now, if you go through
the same argument
with the other operator that we
talked about last time, where
it was D perp mu, D perp mu.
So delta 1.
So same thing as above, but just
having D perp mu, D perp mu.
D n perp mu.
You actually find that it
gives the same result as this.
OK, so if you just have
reparameterization of type one,
then you can't really--
the sum of this and
this would be invariant.
Or the sum of this
and this is invariant,
or the sum of any combination
of 1 minus a times that,
and a times this
would be invariant.
But type two does distinguish
between this operator
and this operator.
If you do a type
two transformation,
you get terms from this
that you can't possibly
cancel by any other term
that you could write down.
And those terms are such that
the power counting, there's
not a subleading operative
that could compensate either.
OK, so going through all
the type two transformations
is kind of messy.
So again, I don't
want to do that.
But I would refer you to
some reading for that.
OK, but if you take these
two things together,
then you do rule out
that additional operator.
And so then, taking
everything together,
we have a unique leading
order Lagrangian.
It's not so easy, actually.
It requires, it requires
looking at the transformations
carefully.
Yeah.
So it is-- so even though I
made it sound like it's simple,
but it's not.
There's a reason why
I don't want to spend
the rest of the class on it.
OK.
So if we put all the
things that we've
talked about last time and this
time together, what we find
is that the Lagrangian
that we've been discussing
is unique for the CN field.
So it's the unique leading order
Lagrangian for the CN field.
And the things that we've used
are power counting in order
to say that the
terms here should
be lambda to the fourth, that's
what leading order meant.
Gauge invariance, make
these covariant derivatives
of appropriate types.
And now also reparameterization
of symmetries.
So as we kind of
discussed last time,
the reparameterization
of symmetries
here can do different things.
They can connect leading order
operators to leading order
operators and hence, constrain
the form of leading order
operators that you write down,
and that's what we just did.
And in particular,
the type two, remember
the epsilon perp was
order of lambda to the 0,
so maybe it's not surprising
that that's what it's doing.
The type one transformation,
the delta perp
took you down a power in lambda,
but if you had some subleading
operator, then it
would also take you
down a power in lambda, so
that's one of the things
that you have to be careful
about when you're sort
of counting powers of lambda.
But there is a
sense, also, in which
reparameterization symmetry
does the same thing
as HQET, which is it connects.
So it can do two
different things.
It can constrain the form
of operators you write down
at lowest order, or it
could connect the Wilson
coefficients, for example,
of leading order operators
to subleading operators.
And that's what we saw on the
problem set in the HQET example
it can do that here too.
And so if we want to
think about that freedom,
then we should note
that there's actually
more kind of reparameterization
than we've talked
about just with this example.
So far, what we've talked
about is changing the basis.
But we could also change
the amount of the momentum
that we stick in the
label versus the residual.
That was also a choice that
we made in doing things.
And we should be careful
to think about that freedom
as well.
And that's also a
reparameterization freedom.
And this one looks,
in some sense,
more like what we
talked about in HQET.
In some sense, what
HQET it is doing
is a combination of
these two things.
Because of the
decomposition of momentum
there is a bit simpler.
So we had this split of
label and residual momenta,
and we thought about
the labels as discrete.
But still, even if
they're discrete
there's a freedom in
how we make this split.
And so we could, if you
like, take our label momentum
or our label momentum
operator, and transform it
by adding some beta, which
has a power counting of order
lambda squared.
And if we make a
compensating transformation
in the residual momentum,
or the residual derivative,
then that would be a symmetry
of the decomposition.
Wouldn't change anything,
end up beta being 0.
Projects onto these two cases.
So if you wrote that as
a change to the field,
then you'd be saying that
the field picks up a phase.
That's the transformation
for the derivatives.
And then, you could
shift the label
by beta, that's the
transformation for the beta,
for the label.
OK, so this is a
different transformation
than the ones we were
talking about over there,
and it's a transformation that
has to do with this freedom.
But basically, what
this freedom does
is it connects the
derivatives to each other.
So it connects this combination,
it does something very simple,
so after you know what
it does it's simpler
just to say what it does
and forget about thinking
about it as a transformation.
It simply connects
the label operator
to be label operator plus
the derivative operator.
OK.
But these two have different
orders in the power counting.
And so what this
will do, is it'll
connect things that
are leading order
to things that are subleading
order, for example.
So one way of saying that
is it that it connects
leaving and subleading
Wilson coefficients,
because you can always
think of the coefficient
as the thing being fixed.
And then it would do it in both
something like a leading order
to subleading order
Lagrangian, or if you also
wrote down operators.
If you wrote down a series
of some external operator,
maybe it's a weak
interaction, then
it could connect as we
saw on the problems set.
It could connect C1 to
C0 like it did in HQET.
OK, so this one
clearly does that.
So after you see that,
then you should think
about the following thing.
Well, this is
reparameterization symmetry.
What did reparameterization
symmetry do here?
It connected label and
residuals to each other.
It said, well, they were
both part of the same thing
in the beginning,
so there should
be some connection later
on in the effective theory,
and that remains true.
It's encoded in this
reparameterization symmetry.
But you can also now
try to think about,
given that we have
these derivatives, what
about gauging that formula?
Gauge symmetry
basically was telling us
how to turn p mu into
a covariant derivative
and partial mu into a
convenient derivative.
So can we think
about combining what
we know from gauge
symmetry together
with reparameterization?
And we actually can,
if we're careful.
And where this is
leading is, we'll
find that there's basically
in the end of the day,
there's very simple--
I don't know if we'll get
there today, but we'll try.
There's very simple
building blocks
that in the end of
the day you can build
all the SCET operators out of.
And we're kind of moving
our way in that direction.
OK, so let's try to gauge this.
n dot label operator is 0.
So for that guy, you just
have i n dot partial,
there's no label operator piece.
And gauging it
just takes you to i
n dot D, which is
the full D that
had both an ultra soft
and collinear piece to it.
And if you look back at how our
transformations were defined
for U c and U ultra
soft, then this guy
is basically just
transforming in the way
that you would want a covariant
derivative to transform,
and it does that under both
types of symmetries, because
of the way we set it up like
a background field for the n
dot a ultra soft.
OK, but that's actually not
really related to this story,
because there is no split
in the n dot p component.
So it's really the other
components, the and the n bar,
where we have to pay more
attention to what's going on.
So if we look at what the
gauge transformations mean
for those components,
it's the same story
but I'm going to
write it out anyway.
OK, so this isn't quite
how we wrote it before.
We wrote it before as a
transformation on the A,
but if you put the
transformation on the A
together with the
derivative then you
can write it like this.
For this piece
here, for example,
remember what this thing is.
This thing here is a label
operator p bar plus g n bar
dot A n.
Label operator
doesn't hit this guy,
there's no label momentum
in the ultra soft U,
so it just goes through that guy
or gives 0, and UU dagger is 1.
So this piece doesn't
contribute there,
and this piece transformed
in this way already.
These ones are slightly more
involved, but what I'm saying
is just a summary of what
we already learned earlier
or talked about earlier.
And then finally, there's also
the ultra soft transformation.
And the ultra soft didn't
transform under the collinear.
And of course it did transform
under the ultra soft.
So this is a summary of
what we said earlier.
So the simplest idea
that you would say,
well, is just like,
take these guys
and replace this by a
covariant derivative and that
by a covariant
derivative, right?
Always useful to think about
the simplest thing first.
So this would be the simplest
thing, and that doesn't work.
The reason that
that doesn't work
is that if you look
at these two pieces,
they don't transform
in the same way.
So if I were to
build operators out
of this guy that are
gauge invariant, then when
I looked at the
collinear transformation,
because this guy doesn't
transform and this guy does,
this whole thing is
not transforming.
So if I just stuck this guy
in, if this guy was invariant,
this guy wouldn't
be, and vise versa.
OK, so this doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: Can you remind me how
the ultra soft field transforms
under collinear with its
label summing conventions?
PROFESSOR: Ultra
soft under collinear?
So this guy didn't transform.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking of the
top equation, in the middle.
i n D goes under--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
So that one's a
little, you know, yeah.
So, you want to know which one?
I can look it up for you.
AUDIENCE: Well the one
you were pointing at,
so that's how the D and the
A n part that transforms,
but the A U soft--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there
something, like,
PROFESSOR: Me remind myself,
then I'll remind you.
So the A ultra slot
never transformed
under the collinear, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess I don't know how--
PROFESSOR: And
then, so then, yeah.
So right.
So how does this work out?
The reason that
this works out is
because there was an n dot A
ultra soft field in the gauge
transformation of the
calendar n dot a field.
That's why it works out.
Good, because it would
take me forever to find it.
All right, so what
are we going to do?
So we need some
kind of compensating
object to make these things
transform in the same way.
And we have such a compensating
object, that's our Wilson line.
So the Wilson line
transformed on one side.
And so we can use it to
modify those formulas
and get a result that,
where both terms transform
in the same way.
I just stick to the W in where
I need it in these two terms.
And then I have set up things
so that the transformation
of the two terms are the same.
And you could call
this, if you wanted
to define some kind
of full D, then this
is the kind of
closest that you can
get to defining a
sort of full D. OK,
so these W's ensure both terms--
it would ensure that under
collinear transformation,
both terms transform at
the U c n, on the outside.
OK, so we could
just stick anywhere
that we have i n
bar dot D perp, we
could just replace it by
this and then expand out.
I.e.
we could get a
subleading term by just
using this operator here.
And we know that that
is going to be there
because of reparameterization
symmetry, which
was connecting the derivatives.
And therefore
connects these two.
And once we put
in gauge cemetery,
then it's-- this is the formula.
So if you go back to what
we talked about earlier,
we said earlier, I said A
mu, for the full theory,
that you could
just sort of think
of it as splitting
between a collinear
and an ultra soft field.
And then I said plus
dot dot dot, OK?
And I said, we'll talk about
what plus dot dot dot is later.
So now is later.
What plus dot dot
dot is, is terms
that you would generate
from, for example,
the derivatives here
hitting the Wilson line,
or expanding out these Wilson
lines, or the gauge field.
And so those are
making it have terms
with more fields
than just one field.
And so, if you thought
about the A in here
as sort of a full theory
A, and the A's in here
as the effective theory,
you could drive a formula
like this one but it would
involve more complicated stuff.
It's not good to think
about it this way,
it's better to think
about it in terms
of the covariant derivatives,
because then you're already
thinking about gauge invariance,
so this formula was useful
earlier, but it's actually
these formulas here
that are the more
useful way of thinking
about taking full
theory derivatives
and turning them into
effective theory results.
All right, so we can
dispense with thinking
about the plus dot dot dot
there because it's better
just to think about
it in this form,
where you can write a
nice closed expression.
OK, so let's do one example
of a subleading term.
So we had an operator that
involved covariate derivatives
that were collinear.
This one.
And if we just use the top
formula there, then we know--
so this is a term
that was in L0.
Then we know that there's a term
in L1 that looks as follows.
And I want to write it
out so you sort of see
how also the gauge
symmetry works out nicely.
OK, so using the fact that I
can write this guy as a Wilson
line.
1 over p bar times
the Wilson line.
And the fact that I get
some Wilson lines when
I look at the subleading term.
So some of the Wilson lines,
I get W-W dagger is 1.
And then the
remaining Wilson lines
are sitting next to collinear
fields in such a way
that this guy here is
collinear gauge invariant,
this guy here is
and then there's an ultra soft
transformation that connects up
all the pieces, OK?
If we didn't have
these W's here,
we wouldn't have got those
W's in the right spots there,
and this operator
that I wrote down here
would not be collinear
gauge invariant.
So this operator is both
collinear and ultra soft gauge
invariant.
But most importantly,
it's collinear gauge
invariant because of
what we did there.
And there's no Wilson
coefficient to this operator.
It's got the same coefficient
as the leading order term,
so there's nothing non-trivial.
We could just use it to
get subleading stuff.
OK.
And you could also do
similar things for currents.
I'm not going to give
examples of that,
but it's also a powerful
tool for connecting
coefficients of
leading and subleading
operators and currents.
Not every operator in
the subleading Lagrangian
is connected.
So there are some that could
not be connected in some order,
but there's actually
more connections
than there are in HQET because
we have more symmetries.
OK, so any questions about that?
OK.
So so far, all of
our discussions
have been about one
collinear field.
When we SCET, we
actually in general
want to talk about more
than one collinear field.
So how would we generalize
everything we've
discussed to more than one?
So we would have, in this case,
more than one energetic hadron,
more than one energetic jet.
So far we've been talking about
one energetic hadron, or one
energetic jet.
What if we have two jets?
Then we would need two types
of collinear field, one
for each of those jets.
And basically,
what we have to do
is take our collinear
Lagrangian--
well let me call it L n
0, which is the fermion
piece plus the gluon piece.
And we sum over n.
We have to sum
over all n's which
are corresponding to individual
distinguishable collinear
fields.
So the question is, what
does it mean, sum over n?
What is the distinction
between collinear fields?
And so here's the
words, and then we'll
explain what they mean.
This sum is over
inequivalent n's,
though that should
be obvious that they
have to be equivalent.
But what makes them
inequivalent is the fact
that they are RPI
equivalence classes.
So that's a funny sentence.
Inequivalent RPI
equivalence classes.
So, two ends are
the same if they
belong in an equivalence class
that could be connected to--
where they could be connected by
reparameterization invariance.
So you should think of the
n's that I'm summing over here
as just members,
one of each class.
They're kind of just picking
out what that class is, just
labeling it by one member.
And then I sum over
an inequivalent set.
So let's just imagine
that we have some n's.
n1, n2, n3.
And we can ask
the question, what
makes them equivalent
or inequivalent?
So let me call them, that the
n i collinear modes for any i
are distinct.
And there's a condition that
if I dot two of these ends
together, they should
not be close together.
And in fact that they
should be some value
that's much bigger
than lambda squared.
Obviously, if i was equal
to j, we would get 0.
But for any i not
equal to j, we will
say the n's are equivalent
if the dot product is much
bigger than lambda squared.
So let's see why it's lambda
squared by doing an example.
So that's, if you
like, how you can
define the equivalence classes.
Let's imagine you have
some momentum, p2, which
is a large piece times n2.
And then you dot n1 into it.
So n1 dot p2 is Q n1 dot n2.
And that would be
of order lambda
squared if n1 dot n2 were
of order lambda squared.
Right?
But if n1 dot n2 are
order lambda squared,
and therefore n1 dot p2
is order lambda squared,
you would say p2 is an
n1 collinear particle,
because this is the right power
counting for an n1 collinear
particle.
So it's both n1 collinear
and n2 collinear,
and that just means
n1 n2 are just
two members of the
same equivalence class.
So if this is true, that the
dot products of order lambda
squared, then n1
and n2 are within
the same equivalence class.
Which if you wanted some
notation, you could say n2
is in the class defined by n1.
So you could really
think of this as sum
over classes but its--
usually people just
write sum over n.
OK, so that is in
some sense clear,
that you want to be summing
over things that are distinct.
In this case of back to back
jets that we talked about,
they're pretty distinct.
One's going this way,
one's going that way.
The n's dotted into
each other are 2,
so that's certainly much
greater the lambda squared.
But in general, this is what
you have to have in order
to make them distinct fields.
So then, everything basically
that we've talked about kind of
goes through again, and I'm
not going to dwell on it,
but I will just kind
of repeat some things.
So collinear gauge
transformations, for example.
You would have now a
new type of scaling
that you can have
for different fields,
and you could have two different
types of collinear gauge
transformations.
One for your n1 collinear
field, one for your n2.
If n1 and n2 are
distinct, then those
will have distinct scalings
for the corresponding momenta,
so they'll be distinct
transformations.
And fields won't transform
under the other guys'--
n1 collinear fields won't
transform under the n2 gauge
transformation
because, again, that
would spoil the power
counting for the momenta.
So at some level
it's very intuitive
to figure out how
the results are.
I'm not going to go through it.
But suffice it to
say that we would
have collinear gauge
transformations
for each collinear guy.
Reparameterization, same story.
We have separate invariances
for each pair of n's.
So n1 and n1 bar,
for the n1 sector.
We have a
reparameterization symmetry.
n2 and n2 bar for the n2 sector.
Reparameterization
symmetry, et cetera.
And here is actually
where you see
that there's something that
looks different than Lorentz
invariance that's going on.
Because the
reparameterization are only
acting within a sector.
So if you do an n1 type
reparameterization,
there's no transformation
of an n2 type Wilson line,
or an n2 type gauge field.
So an n1 transformation
affects the n1 collinear fields
and objects, n2 type,
which could affect that.
And it's more like a
Lorentz transformation
that sort of acts within
the sector all by itself.
But it's not really a
Lorentz transformation,
it's just
reparameterization symmetry.
OK?
But it's exactly the
transformations we wrote down,
just you don't transform n2
type fields when you do an n1.
And, just like we had before,
if you do matching calculations
you get Wilson
lines, but now there
can be more than one type.
So we had this W Wilson
line that showed up,
and we did matching
calculations.
And I want to give
you here one example
which we'll come back and
talk about more later on,
and which we've
already mentioned.
So consider our
example of e plus e
minus producing two jets.
So in the full
theory, you would just
have a vector current
from the photon.
And if you want to match that
onto the two jet operator,
you can go through
the same type of thing
that we did when we were doing
the B to S gamma example.
And the difference is here
that we get two different types
of Wilson lines.
So this n1 Wilson line, W n1.
My notation here is
that the subscript
is supposed to indicate
to you that it's
n1 bar of A n1 that shows up.
And then likewise, W n2 is a
function of n2 bar dot A n2.
So you have to
decide whether you're
going to call it W
sub n2 bar or n2,
but anyway this is my notation.
So you get Wilson lines that
are built out of the n1 bar
dot A n1 field, which are order
of lambda 0, or the n2 bar
dot A n2 fields, which
were order lambda 0.
So this is lambda 0,
and this is lambda 0.
By power counting
we can certainly
get objects like that.
And when you go through
the process of integrating
our off shell particles, just
like we did for B to S gamma
where we attach
gluons and we found
that some lines
were off shell, so
we had to integrate them out.
If you do that for this
process, you get this operator.
So when we construct
the effective theory,
we have to integrate out off
shell particles and doing so
generates this
Wilson mine operator.
It's a little more
complicated in this case
because we get these
two Wilson lines.
And I'll talk a little bit more
later on in a different context
about what type of diagrams are
involved in getting these two
different Wilson lines.
But the result
is, in some sense,
more intuitive than a
way of getting there.
What's happening is, you're
getting this W n1 Wilson line
next to the C n1 field, and
then this form of combination
here is gauge invariant
under the n1 collinear gauge
transformations.
And the same thing here.
This guy doesn't transform
under the n1 collinear gauge
transformations.
This guy does, this
guy's invariant.
This guy's invariant
under n2 collinear gauge
transformations.
They both transform under ultra
soft gauge transformation,
so they get connected
in that way.
And again, you have--
if you just think
about gauge symmetry
and how it should come
out, then you would have
guessed that it should be this.
But you can also
derive it this way.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for the
one collinear receptor,
it's been very top-down.
Is this, when you start to
throw in [INAUDIBLE] would you--
PROFESSOR: So this is the
top-down way of thinking,
that you just generate
it by integrating out.
And you can do that.
Do It to all orders
of the tree level
diagrams, that's possible.
Or you can-- but we're starting
to see a picture emerge
from the bottom up, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
I'm talking about the top order.
So that's pretty bottom-up
only, is there a way of,
because you're saying
let's now state
that the effective theory has
many copies of the collinear
gauge.
PROFESSOR: So.
Right.
So I mean, you could try to
think of writing a formula,
right?
You could start, try to think
of it like, let's take A,
and let's write A.
Let's just do two.
Right.
You could start
trying to do that.
But at some point, it just
loses its friendliness.
It's not really
buying you anything.
So, starting to think
from the bottom up
is actually a good way
of going at this point.
You could still do
it from the top down,
but it just gets more
and more cumbersome.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
All right.
So let's come back and study are
our leading order Lagrangian.
And actually, we've
already learned something
about factorization although
we don't know it yet.
So what is this
word, factorization?
One way of thinking about
what factorization is, is it's
how different degrees of
freedom talk to each other.
And given that we
have a leading order
Lagrangian for the collinear
and ultra soft fields,
we should know something
about how collinear and ultra
soft fields talk to each other.
So let's come back
and study Lcc 0.
So the propagator, if we read
out what the propagator is,
if we're careful about
signs of i epsilons--
We had both particles
and antiparticles.
You can think of
the antiparticles
as the guys that
have the minus i0.
And if you combine these
two things together,
then that's just giving
you the thing that we
got when we expanded QCD.
So when you think
about deriving it
from the [? SCET ?]
Lagrangian, you
think about getting this piece.
But then you have
to also sum over
the other pieces with the
other side of the n bar dot p,
and you get this piece and
they come back to that thing.
So this is the particles.
If I want to split out the
particles and antiparticles
I can do this.
This is the particles that have
n bar dot p greater than 0,
and this is the antiparticles.
In this notation where n bar dot
p falls, the fermion line flow,
we have n bar dot p less than 0.
OK, so that, in some
sense, we already
alluded to, that the
propagator works out correctly.
This is showing it explicitly.
What about interactions?
Well, I want to be
interested in a minute
about ultra soft
interactions because they're
kind of special.
For the ultra soft
gluons, only n
dot A ultra soft showed
up at leading order.
In the LCC 0.
So if we look at the Feynman
rule there, we have this--
let's give this guy an index mu.
And this guy is ultra soft.
This guy is collinear.
Then the Feynman rule just
has n mu in it, not gamma mu.
OK?
So that's an observation
that we know from our LCC 0
and that just comes from--
remember this just
comes from the i n
dot D term because
that's the only term that
had the ultra soft
gauge field in it.
But there's another fact
that our Lagrangian told us.
And that is that only the n
dot k ultra soft momentum,
so if I call this momentum
k, only the component n
dot k was also showing
up in the propagators.
So there's a gauge field
statement as well as
a statement about the
ultra soft momenta.
And that was due to the
multi-pole expansion
that we did.
So if we do that at
the level of thinking
about some kind of diagram--
so let's think about some
type of diagram like this,
and let's look at
this propagator here.
That propagator-- we
brought this up before
but let me write it out again.
So if I say p is this
guy, and k is this guy,
then this guy is p plus
k, but k being ultra soft,
these guys are supposed to
be ultra soft, let's say.
k being ultra soft, only
the n dot k shows up
in that propagator.
And if we work on shell,
for p squared of 0,
so let me first rewrite this
so you can see where I'm going.
I can form a full p
squared in the denominator
from the terms that depend on p.
That's just the full p
squared of the particle.
And if this guy is an external
particle as it is in my figure,
then p squared would be 0.
OK, so if I go to the on shell
case, p squared equals zero,
then this just becomes n
bar dot p, n bar dot p,
n dot k, plus i0, which is
looking like just 1 over n
dot k.
So it's becoming very simple.
For cleaner gluons
it would, of course,
not be-- it would
be no simplification
like that possible, but for the
ultra soft particles there is.
And so what has just happened
is that the propagator
is becoming eikonal.
So our collinear
propagator reduces
to the eikonal approximation,
which is just 1
over n dot k, when appropriate.
And when appropriate means
when it's interacting
with ultra soft fields.
So we can kind of
summarize that for all
the different possible
cases in the following way.
So you could have, if you want
to be careful about signs,
you can think about
attaching ultra soft gluons
to a fermion coming in
or a fermion going out.
Or likewise, to a antiparticle
coming in or going out.
We always take k going up.
And if I work with the
external particle on shell,
then combining together the
Feynman rule for the vertex
and the rule for
the propagator, I'm
getting these what are called
sometimes eikonal vertices,
or propagator vertices.
So these are eikonal.
Eikonal in both the
interactions and in the vertex.
And that's what should happen
for having a very soft particle
talking to something
very energetic, that's
called the eikonal approximation
and it just falls out
of our effective field theory.
So this can actually
lead us to something
deeper, which is called ultra
soft collinear factorization.
So let's consider
more than one gluon.
He'll have one collinear
fermion and we'll just
touch a bunch of ultra
soft gluons to it.
Kind of obvious notation.
Let's call it m.
So we could sum
up those diagrams,
and if we sum up
those diagrams we
get something that
looks familiar.
So sum over m, sum
over permutation.
Factors of g.
Gauge fields.
OK.
Be careful about ordering.
And I'm working here on shell.
So that external
collinear particle
has p squared equals 0.
So if you think about what this
is, it's just our Wilson line.
It's not the same Wilson line
that we were talking about
before.
This Wilson line is built
from ultra soft fields, not
collinear fields.
And it doesn't even point
in the same direction,
it points in the n direction,
not the n bar direction.
But it is a Wilson line.
AUDIENCE: Are these incoming?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think so.
AUDIENCE: I think you put
a minus sign in the top.
PROFESSOR: So for this guy,
there's no minus sign there
because, well, I didn't
tell you what the--
there could be a minus g
or a plus g here, right?
Yeah.
That's minus g, probably.
OK.
So actually, what
this motivates us
to do from the effective
theory point of view
is to consider the following.
It motivates us to think about
making a field redefinition
because what we just did is we
iterated the leading order L 0
Lagrangian over and over again
to get these vertices as well
as the propagators.
And we ended up with something
that was just a Wilson line.
Could we capture that
somehow, in a simpler way?
And the answer is yes, if
we make the following field
redefinition.
We take our original
CNP field and we
pull out a Wilson
line, Y. And we
can do a similar thing
for the gauge field.
This is just the adjoint version
of the same field redefinition,
where Y is a Wilson line, which
corresponds to that in momentum
space and in position space.
Pathway to exponential.
So when I say that
the Wilson line's
at x, that means I've
shifted the whole line by x.
And I could just denote
that by putting an x here.
And then from that
point in space time,
there's a line going
out in the n direction.
That's what this
formula is saying.
So at S equals zero,
you just sit at x.
This should be a picture.
Oh, this is minus infinity so
it's not a very good picture.
And so this Wilson line,
like any Wilson line,
has an equation of
motion, which is this.
It satisfies Y dagger Y is one.
And if you go through
with our transformation
for the collinear gluon, which
I could have also motivated
in this way.
If I'd gone through
the calculation where
instead of having a
collinear quark here
I had a collinear
gluon, I would have
found exactly the same thing,
except all these A's would be
in the adjoint representation.
I didn't write the
t's anyway, so.
All right.
So either the fundamental
representation
or the adjoint
representation, and that
would motivate you to make the
same type of field redefinition
to try to capture
what's going on there.
OK.
So let's see what that
does to our Lagrangian.
So our original Lagrangian--
I'm not going to write
out all the terms.
Just enough terms
to get you the idea.
If I make this
field redefinition,
it goes to this guy with a
superscript 0 that I'm writing.
And then-- let me
write out here.
Let me split this
derivative into two pieces.
So I'm still not writing in
the terms there in the dot.
So what I did is I took the
Y from this guy and the Y
from that guy and I put them
inside the square bracket.
This n dot D, remember,
has two pieces.
It's i n dot D is sort of an i
n dot D ultra soft, which just
has the ultra soft gauge
field, but then there's
a piece that involves the
collinear gauge field.
But then the
collinear gauge field
also transforms, as
I wrote up there.
So I get this Y, Y
dagger for that guy.
So for the collinear
gauge field,
these Y's are cancelling.
And this guy here, if
you push the derivative
through the Y using this
formula, then the Y's are also
canceling and this is just
becoming i n dot partial.
So that's becoming
i n dot partial,
and this is becoming
n dot a n of 0.
So what's happening is
that the ultra soft gauge
field is dropping out.
Now there's terms in
the plus dot dot dot,
those terms involve the D perp
slash and the 1 over n bar
dot D. And if I had
written out those terms,
too, then the same thing
would happen, actually.
All the Y's would cancel
out in those terms as well.
So what I'm getting
here is something
that I might call an n dot Dn.
It's a covariant derivative that
only involves the A n0 field.
And there's actually
no soft fields
at all left in the Lagrangian
after I make this field
redefinition.
So that's obviously giving us
a very much simpler Lagrangian.
OK, so it looks like
a good thing to do.
And that, if you go
through it, is actually
true also for the gluon action.
Gluon action was also built
of n dot D type fields, type
covariant derivatives,
that's where
the ultra soft gluon showed up,
and basically the same thing
happens.
This same relation
right there means
that the ultra soft gluon would
decouple from that Lagrangian
as well.
So making this
field redefinition,
we actually decoupled in the
Lagrangians the ultra soft
and the collinear fields.
So even though the effective
theory allowed these modes
to couple to each other, they
coupled in a very simple way.
And so what we're saying is that
it's convenient because they
couple in such a simple way.
If they didn't couple in such
a simple way, we would stop
and we'd just use that
Lagrangian, we'd do physics.
Since they do a couple
in such a simple way,
we can do physics in terms of
some reparameterized variables,
or redefined variables, which
are these new variables.
And that's convenient
because now,
if I think about our
original Lagrangian,
it goes over to
something that looks
simpler because it's going
over to something that has no--
the L0 has no ultra soft fields.
This wouldn't be, of course,
true for the L1 or higher order
Lagrangians, it
actually would still
simplify all those
Lagrangians a certain way.
But for the leading
order one, it
seems to make a dramatic
simplification because we
no longer have this coupling.
So you might think, well,
the interactions have all
disappeared.
But they haven't disappeared,
because when you make the field
redefinition, you can't just
make it to the Lagrangian.
You also have to make it on
operators in their theory.
And what this does is it
moves some interactions out
of the Lagrangian
and into currents.
So let's do some
examples about it.
Since it's for the Lagrangian,
it's always the same.
That's one of the reasons
why this is powerful,
because if we do it
once and for all,
we just did it for
the Lagrangian.
And then we can see
what happens for a bunch
of different currents, so
I'll do three examples.
So one example that we had
was this current for B to S
gamma, which had a heavy quark
field and a one light collinear
up quark, and a Wilson line.
I should have said
another thing that I'm
using, which is important.
It's that if you
go through what--
let me make sure I got
my Y, or my Y dagger's
on the right side.
If you go through what happens
for the collinear Wilson line
after the field redefinition,
this guy remember,
is written in terms
of these fields.
And this guy here is written
in terms of those fields.
And it also gets
Y's on the outside.
That's important when you
start considering, for example
these dots or--
OK.
But I need that here.
So given that that's also true,
if I want to look at this guy,
I just make the
field redefinition.
So I got this.
I got a Y, Y dagger on both
sides of the Wilson line.
These guys cancel each other.
This is a Wilson line 0.
I have C bar 0,
Wilson line zero.
And I have gamma.
And I have Y dagger, hv.
So now I have a
Wilson line sitting
next to the heavy quark and
another Wilson line sitting
next to the collinear quark.
So all the, if you
think in the diagram
that we drew, the
interactions that
were those gluons attaching
to the collinear quark,
they're now just all represented
by this Wilson line here.
But it's even more than
that, because we also
transformed the Wilson line.
So even if we had attached ultra
gluons to that Wilson line,
they all magically
simplify into a simple,
one simple Wilson line Y dagger.
So from a diagrammatic
point of view,
if we had actually tried to
carry out the calculation that
would give this formula, it
would be kind of horrendous
because there's an enormous
amount of calculations going on
to give this.
It just looks complicated
in the diagrams,
but here it looks very simple.
And the fact that the leading
order Lagrangian gave us 0
there tells us that it really
is the sum of the diagrams.
Let's have a couple
more examples.
So you could take our
example for two jets,
and you could ask what
would happen in that case.
What's the generalization if
I have more than one collinear
direction?
And the generalization is that
you just make the same field
redefinition, but it's
a different component
of the ultra soft field that
couples to different collinear
fields.
So you're making a different--
you're making a
field redefinition
that's appropriate to each
of the different collinear
sectors.
But other than that it goes
through in the same way.
And so here, this Y
n1 dagger involves
n1 dot A ultra soft
fields, and this guy here
involves n2 dot A
ultra soft fields.
And they don't
cancel, but they do
simplify all the interactions,
in this case simplify
to the simple Y
dagger Y combination.
OK, so having more than one
clear direction is not--
I mean, it means that you
have more than one type
of Y showing up.
But again, it's just the
leading order Lagrangian
for each of those
sectors that tell
you what's going to show up.
Type of Y. Let's do
one more example.
Let's do an example where we
have collinear fields that
are in the following form.
Where both directions are n.
And we have an
operator like that.
So it's the same operator
I was writing down here,
but in this case, I
had n1 n2 for two jets.
I haven't really told
you about an example that
would involve this
operator here,
but it turns out
this operator here
is something that
shows up, for example,
in a part time distribution
function and other places.
So this operator also does
make an appearance in physics.
And if you look at what
happens for this operator,
all the Y's cancel.
So when you go through
the transformation,
you have Y, Y dagger, but
then the Y's exactly cancel.
So in that case,
it's really true
that the ultra soft gluons
are dropping out effectively
when you add up
diagrams that there's
no ultra soft gluons left.
In these cases, the leftover
is these Wilson lines that
are showing up in the operator.
In this case,
there's no left over.
AUDIENCE: Are those both
values in the same position?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Y to the w?
PROFESSOR: Because, yeah.
So they would if
I just wrote this.
In general, what you could have
inserted in here is some kind
of something that
picks out, like,
the momentum of
one of those w's.
So let me just throw that
delta function in there
so they don't cancel.
We'll talk about that
in a minute or two.
Yeah.
But in general, I
could cancel them
in this particular formula.
But there's reasons
why, actually, we
won't want to cancel
them, because we
will be putting other
things in between that
won't change what I just said.
So imagine that
you had something
that measured the
momentum of one
of these products of fields.
It would still be true that
these Y's, which are not
having labels, would cancel
in the way that we said,
but the w's wouldn't cancel.
OK, so this is called the
BPS field redefinition,
and S is me.
And this thing sums up an
infinite class of diagrams.
What it does in
example one, if you
want to think about what the
diagrams would look like,
let me draw kind of
an example for you.
So let's have some
collinear particles.
And just to make
it look nontrivial,
let me draw something it
seems kind of nontrivial.
So there's a bunch of
collinear particles,
and then we could add
ultra soft gluons to them.
And the ultra soft
gluons can couple
to all those collinear
particles, the gluons,
the quarks, everybody.
If we consider all
the ultra soft gluons
coupling to the collinear
particles everywhere,
and we add up all
those attachments,
then it just becomes
a single Wilson line.
So this thing becomes
And then times exactly the
same collinear structure.
So what I'm saying doesn't
rely, since we did it
at the level of Lagrangian, it
doesn't rely on whether or not
they're loops, or tree
level, or anything like that.
So this diagram there, if we
add up all possible attachments,
will be equal to that one.
Where this is a Y. In this
case, it's a Y dagger.
OK, so that's the simplicity
encoded in this formula right
here.
This is an example of J1.
In example three, then,
it's a little simpler, even.
Because the ultra soft gluons
are decoupling at lowest order
from any graph that
you might consider.
So you go through
the same exercise,
but now that the Y's
are all canceling out.
And this has a name that
sometimes people use,
called color transparency.
So one place that it
shows up is the following.
Let's take our
current J3 and imagine
that we produce from that
current an energetic pion.
That was one of the examples
we talked about when
we were talking about BDD pi.
So there's a collinear pion,
and these are collinear quarks.
collinear quark and anti quark.
Supposed to be inside the pion,
and there's collinear gluons.
If we attach all the ultra
soft gluons to this object,
then the Wilson lines cancel.
The ultra soft
gluons are decoupling
from energetic particles.
And the reason that
they're decoupling
is because the partons
here are in a color singlet
state, which is this pion.
OK, so here we're producing
a color neutral pion
out of color contracted
collinear quark fields,
and there's these
Wilson lines for reasons
we'll discuss in a minute.
How they kind of play
a role in physics here.
But the reason that
Wilson lines are canceling
is because the collinear
things were already contracted.
All the collinear
things in n direction
were contracted in a color
singlet, global color singlet.
So the words that go along with
this phrase color transparency
is that you have these
very soft gluons,
and they're trying to come
in and see this thing.
But they can't
really, all they can
see is sort of the overall
color charge of the whole thing.
They couple, of the
multi-pole expansion,
they're only coupling
to a single component,
and you can think of
that as if they're only
seeing an overall color charge.
And therefore, since
it's overall color
charge is neutral, you don't
see, they just cancel out.
OK.
In my notes, I also
have a page talking
about how you could think
of gauge transformations
after making this
field redefinition,
but it's kind of an
aside so I'm not going
to talk about it in lecture.
But I will post it.
OK, so what about these?
What about this
additional kind of thing
that I was alluding to here?
How does that come
in to our story?
So, so far in our
story, we haven't really
talked about Wilson
coefficients except
to say that they
could be constrained
by reparameterization
invariance to be absent.
So let's think about
Wilson coefficients now.
Obviously that's
something important.
And the way that Wilson
coefficients can come in
is the following way.
They can depend on the large
momenta that we're at order 1.
And one way of denoting
that is by saying that they
depend on label operators.
OK, so nothing stops that.
But if we want the momentum
that's picked up by this label
operator to be gauge
invariant, then we
should act on products
of fields that
are collinear gauge invariant.
So the way that we should set
it up is to have an operator.
Here's a kind of notation
that's sometimes used.
Where the operator acts on both
fields, the C bar and the W.
Because of our formulas
for the label operator,
we could also write this
as a label operator acting
to the left if we wanted.
So, what this Wilson
coefficient is the function.
It's not just simply a number.
And it picks out the momentum
of this product of fields.
And that's because that product
is collinear gauge invariant.
So it's a well-defined
thing to talk about.
OK, so that's actually
the general structure,
that whenever we have these
products of fields that
are collinear gauge invariant,
if we ask what the Wilson
coefficient could
be a function of,
it can be a function of the
momentum of those products.
So one way of writing this in a
sort of more elegant fashion as
follows.
So take this guy, and write
it as a delta function
in the following way.
So if I do the integral
over this omega,
then I would just get back
that I stick the p bar
dagger inside the
Wilson coefficient,
and that it acts on
this product of fields.
But if I write it
this way, what I get
is that my Wilson
coefficients are just
functions of a number, not
functions of an operator.
And my operators have these
delta functions in them.
But then could depend
on some variables
that are distinguishing
those delta functions.
OK.
So in general, products
of fields like this,
we have to think about their
momenta as being something
that we could label.
If you like, we could
label it by omega.
Because it's a linear
gauge invariant concept,
the Wilson coefficients can
depend on those momenta,
and then we have
Wilson coefficients
that depend on those momenta
and operators that are just
labeled by those momenta.
And this is the
convolution formula
that I sort of promised you at
the beginning of the discussion
of SCET that was going to show
up, and now it's shown up.
OK, so Wilson coefficients can
depend on those large order 1
momenta.
And traditionally they're
written as integrals,
even though you could think
of them as sums at this point
and it wouldn't make
much difference.
So this here is what's called
hard collinear factorization.
In the traditional
QCD literature.
Because it's telling you how
hard degrees of freedom, which
are encoded in our
Wilson coefficients,
can talk to collinear
degrees of freedom,
which are encoded
in our operators.
In SCET, that's just
come out of the formalism
in a very sort of simple way.
In QCD, you'd have to
use word identities
and work hard to get
what I just derived
for you in a couple of lines.
So we're kind of done
for today, and we've
seen kind of two examples
of mode factorization
in the effective theory.
collinear and ultra soft fields
and collinear and hard degrees
of freedom, and
how it simplifies
the discussion of factorization
which is kind of traditional,
in a more traditional language
which I haven't taught you,
but you can believe
me is more complicated
than what we've discussed.
So we'll talk a little bit
more about this next time.
And then we'll talk about how
the ideas that we have here
lead us just to define
a set of objects
that we build operators from.
And once we know what
those objects are,
then we can kind of dispense
with a lot of the steps
that we've done and just jump
right to building operators out
of those objects.
But the steps are
necessary to understand
why it's those objects that we
want to build operators from.
OK.
So any questions?
So we'll talk a little bit
about how this generalizes
to other operators next time.
So that's just the
one time I did here.